which is more difficult the selection
process for special forces
or climbing everest twice um
i'd have to say climbing everest um
selection you know six months essay
selection just seems to
it's drawn out over six months right and
when you start you're already a
you're already a seasoned soldier like
for me i've done one tour
of iraq and two tours of afghanistan so
you almost
get to that stage where you you want to
prove yourself as
as a soldier and i was you know 24 years
old
like full of testosterone um
so like you go on selection with a bunch
of other lads and you're all
you know you've got this unified kind of
cause that you're all trying to that
you're all going for at the same time
um and i actually enjoyed selection
for that reason um because you meet
you know you you end up all that you
know you start with maybe 150 170 people
um after the first three weeks you kind
of down to 50
and then after the next six weeks you
you kind of down to maybe
20 25 people and these 20 25 people have
been through through absolute [ __ ] so
you end up forming this like super tight
bond where
you're all really close and and all
really clicky and then
you get to the end of selection after
that six months you get given
your stable belt and you bury
and you get like a picture tuck next to
clock tower
you shake everyone's hand and then you
disappear into whatever regiment and
squadrons that you go to and then the
next day you kind of
big boys rules into the into the mix
thrown into the lines then
yeah and i remember i remember turning
up day one and
like i was 24 like it's quite a young
age to pass election
and um like the rest of the guys in my
troop were all kind of
i mean some of them were touching 40
years old so there's a 24 year old
turning into
turning up into this this sas troop with
a load of 40 year olds
even like the guy who came in two years
before me he was like
you know two three years ahead of me and
uh
like they're all like big guys like big
kind of
men with like gray hair and stuff and
big hands massive hands
massive hands like you know we had
billy was one of our um one of our
senior sergeants at the time and
you know he was like uh you know x
x kind of football hooligan from london
and just covered in like skull tattoos
and
and like flames of his arms very
welcoming
like yeah we we actually went to norway
on our first exercise and i ended up
spending it
spending the whole uh six weeks living
in a tent with him
so we uh we got on quite well very cozy
after a while yeah
yeah as it turns out he was the nicest
guy there that's awesome man
yeah and how does that relate to everest
then
yeah so like everest is
everest is like quite a big it's a big
misconception for some people
um because a lot of people think that
because of the amount of people that go
up and
and the caliber of people that go up
it's an easy thing to do
and coming from someone who's done a lot
of difficult things in their life
everest is by no means an easy feat
it just seems to attract people who can
afford it because it comes with a
very high price tag so it kind of
attracts a certain
caliber of people and you do end up with
a lot of
a lot of dross on the mountain which
doesn't give it a very
good reputation but everest is more
it's six weeks of
living at altitude so if you think like
altitude just basically takes away
energy from you so if you stand up and
walk
10 meters at sea level it's fine right
you don't think about it
but if you're a you know six seven
thousand meters in the sky
and you stand up and walk 10 meters you
know
you're taking a couple of steps stopping
breathing taking a couple of steps
stopping breathing so like everything
that you deemed
easy at sea level is magnified in
difficulty
the further up you go to the point of
on your summit push when you know if you
think of your summit push it's quite
just to give a picture of of kind of the
severity of it
you do like in a client you get up to
base camp you do an acclimatization
which takes five days or six days you
come back down you rest at base camp
which is at 5 600 meters and then
you kind of sit there and look at the
weather windows
and you get you always get one weather
window to summer which is clear skies
you know
minimal winds you sometimes get two
weather windows
and you rarely get three so it's this
balance of
looking at all your weather weather
systems and speaking to delight people
around the camps and finding out what's
going on
because like you've invested all this
time right you've invested like the last
three weeks of living at altitude eating
[ __ ] food um you know [ __ ] into a
hole in the ground
every morning a frozen frozen hole in
the ground
i throat like you lit it's like
clockwork every morning and
you know your only entertainment is the
game of cards that you play at night in
the tent
by this time you're sick of lunch and
meat and rice um
so you invested all this energy and time
into
making the right decision and getting to
the you know getting
high up and summiting in the in the
right weather window because if you
don't that's it you know
you only get one shot at summit and then
you kind of set off at camp
three on your summit push so you'll
leave camp three which is
seven thousand meters um and there's
four camps till summer so you go camp
three seven thousand meters
leave there at five a.m on oxygen you
climb up to camp four
arrive at camp four say 4 p.m
so that's a full day to get there camp 4
is 8 000 meters
so you rest there in a tent for
you know six hours you try and get some
sleep you get some hot water on you
cook some food um and then you leave
that
night at 8pm to summer
for first light so you know 6am 7am in
the morning
and then you've got all that day to come
all the way back down to camp two
which you get to camp to at say
like i got there about 9pm so
it's a 15-hour day at ridiculous
altitude
yeah so you start 5am it's like two days
basically just constantly
with no sleep minimal water
at that altitude your body doesn't work
the same so you don't
digest food um so i was literally living
off
like the little energy sachets that like
cyclists and triathletes and that use
which obviously then you know i ended up
with that just all over my hands just
like
sticky and it just leaks out into your
pockets every time you put your hand in
your pocket your hand gets stuck
um you not drink as much water just
because you're constantly needing to
move and
kind of beyond camp four up to the
summit
it it's your body's kind of that
drained and tired and exhausted
it's simply just that one foot in front
of the other that slow
kind of monotonous like tap
tap tap and then you kind of you just
see everyone doing it everyone kind of
puts their arm like their elbows on the
legs and like because you're on like a
steep hill and just
just gives it like a few couple of puffs
of breath and just
composes themselves before they set off
again
um and then you get to the top and then
coming down to even worse because it's
steep ground
and that you've got this this mass of
people are coming down at the same time
so you you know you're trying to
work your way through all these people
for like the next
for the next 17 so you sum it six a.m
i'm not i'm no good at math so at 6am
get back down for 10 p.m so what's that
16 14 hours of walking downhill
where your toes are just hitting the
front of your boots for 14 hours
to the point you know you start walking
sideways
backwards yeah you just
like like i've been exhausted and tired
and like fatigued and
so many times in like a military career
but like you're never that
fatigued and exhausted that you are on
everest
it seems like a big part of that is the
camaraderie that you had in the support
structure
from when you were doing special forces
selection
i guess as well like if you've in thin
air
and it's really cold and you're on a
thin ridge
it's like first off you spread out
second you've got to save your breath to
be able to focus on the few
bodily functions that your physiology is
still
able to do uh whereas as you said during
your special
special forces you're really able you've
got this sort of unity that that
binds you all together and makes maybe
the suffering a little bit less
solo yeah a little bit i think
you know for a start you're at sea level
so that makes things way easier
um yeah like
i guess when you're at sea level and
you're doing the things that you do in
the special forces
you always know where the end is and the
end's usually quite comfortable
so say you're deploying an operation
that is
anything from you know 10 hours 12 hours
on a night raid or you go out for a week
and live in a building and put an open
or whatever it is
and you always know at the end of that
you take enough food you take enough
water you know you're warm
you're taking enough um you know
sleeping equipment or enough jackets and
warm clothing that
you're going to be you're going to be
semi-comfortable right there might be a
little bit hardship you might be walking
in with some
some weight in some kit you do the job
you extract or whatever it is
um but you know at the end of that week
actually unless the job or mission
changes
you're gonna come back to base or
wherever it is that you you live with it
you're in the uk you come back you're
probably you know having beers with the
boys
at the weekend or whatever or if it's if
you're overseas you know you're coming
back to a camp you do kitten
you're going for steak and eggs in the
morning you're gonna get back in the gym
um whereas like on everest it's like you
set off on that summit window
and that rotation on that summit window
is seven days
so you leave base camp
you leave base camp with a rucksack and
you come back in seven days with that
same rucksack
and um and you you know you're not
coming back to steak and eggs
and beers are the boys and a warm shower
you're literally i mean you know you
come back to a hot water
you know hot bucket of water and a
little bit of leftover like shampoo that
about a slightly bigger slightly bigger
hole in the ground
to have a poop yeah well everyone's just
been like filling it in once you've been
gone so it's like overflowing oh no
no no no please make it stop
um it's not like that hotel room in
dubai this is
it is lovely out here
you